i guess we should start with the first
store there yeah
so the first store was slashing bun
which is what we wanted to go to last
year as well yes but unfortunately we
couldn't get approval one time yeah this
year since we knew we planned ahead yeah
yeah okay huge huge shout out to uh
geeksplus for actually sorting this out
like last year last year uh malin sorted
it out in like five days or something
before we were going to film this time
we had they had a bit more time but
everything went smoothly
like three weeks or something this time
yeah we learned a lesson and like most
of the stores a lot of the stores we
went to we got to like have free reign
over them without our customers which
was fun as [ __ ] yeah dashimbong was
great especially because we got to go in
before the store even opened so yeah
move whole floors to ourselves just like
going to legoland without anyone there
yeah it was like [ __ ] like awesome
younger me's dream yeah honestly
you've you've lived out the dream
this is like this is actually an actual
dream right like this is the [ __ ] you
wake up as a kid being like i have
infinite budget to spend in this store
and i can buy anything
oh and you have to buy a figure that we
chose for you one of the stores gone
it's great yeah yeah brilliant so do you
guys remember what your challenges were
for this store so yeah i've got two
challenges for this one i remember i got
[ __ ] immediately um so so we actually
actually knew what challenges were in
trash taste good do we have trash taste
good is is he trash box i'm sorry i kept
calling him
trashbox trash so we actually knew the
challenges this time um because we
didn't know them last time and we picked
some easy challenges and some harder
challenges uh that would be harder to
complete you just killed trashbox yeah
my god hillslive
and uh i started off with some of the
hardest challenges what were your
challenges got my challenge was one
find an anime figure or find a figure
from a game that conor has played now i
play a lot of games
now now normally this would be easy yeah
we're talking about akihabara yeah
famous for selling anime figures and
maybe jrpg figures you know um a lot of
japanese ips
it was basically games that conor is not
so well in every store there was
multiple games that i had played so if
you've got this in any store you'd have
been fine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if
you pay attention no there was a lot of
time that was just a big one there was a
lot of turn-based rpgs a lot of
story-based games yeah i went
um and then my second chance challenge
was find the most expensive figure in
the store and uh buy it oh yeah that's
right if these boys found a more
expensive figure
then you don't get the point then i
don't get the points easy that's right
and what your two challenges joey my two
challenges were fairly easy so my first
one was buy a jojo figure and make the
same pose and i mean you know georgia
figures it everywhere especially yeah so
that wasn't easy given the second one i
had to kind of uh you know use my
thinking cap a little bit it was i had
to buy a figure that can beat goku
and i have to not only buy the figure
but i have to convince these two boys
that this character can beat you and the
audience is
i think i figured it out i won't be
easily impressed in fact i might even be
argumentative about it wow it's almost
like i'm on trash
my two challenges were buy a not anime
figure yeah which is very difficult
which is tough in rasheem
uh yeah it was uh because a lot of the
games either had anime or animations and
i knew that you guys would be [ __ ]
and if i bought something that if it
wasn't anime but had some animation yeah
you would give me [ __ ] right um and
there were shows that i thought didn't
have animes that apparently are getting
animes and i thought geez all right [ __ ]
um
and the other one was uh just pick a
figure blindfolded oh wow okay so i just
span around in one section that one's
not tough it's just it could end up very
badly it didn't end up great okay
it didn't
we'll see okay we'll see then okay all
right so wait how many figures did you
guys buy in lashing bun
three three three all right same here
three okay we started things off like
for me
lashing man had so many good figures
yeah right it had a lot of high quality
figures and aside from mandarake it
actually had the most expensive figures
that i could find yeah i did yeah which
uh [ __ ] me over obviously
like well on that note then go on what
is the what is the most expensive figure
we'll go for that last oh okay i gotta
go okay so we don't know any of the
figures that each other bought i got
glimpses of one or two but i overall i
don't know what you guys purchased and i
hope that you guys don't know what i
bought not gonna lie because russian was
so early in the morning and i was still
like in the waking up process i remember
half the [ __ ] i bought it rushing
well i only bought three so it's really
easy for me at lashing bun like i spent
all of my time trying to complete my
challenges right so i like i didn't even
consider the overall challenges i even
forgot that we had overall challenges
because i was just trying to like i used
up all of my time completing every like
my all my challenges because i remember
the store was like opening up the
general public and i was like rushing to
get my figures onto like are you rushing
man
okay that's not funny
maybe million laughs though
of course melin
i remember joey like looking at me and
he's like oh you haven't got your
figures yet and i'm just like no i
completed my challenges in like 10
minutes yeah yeah mama pretty and the
rest of the 50 minutes i was just
perusing because because both of them
had me looking around a lot so the
second challenge which i did second
um which was after perusing around to
try and find the most expensive figure
was trying to find a figure from a game
that connor has played well why don't
you tell the story while introducing the
figure yeah okay well which one do you
think it is okay well
i'll tell the story because the figure
is not actually that big right because
because i had the most expensive figure
challenge i tried to go on a budget at
this point because it was the beginning
of the day and so i look around i look
around what figures are available with a
dashing bun i look around there's final
fantasy no connor's definitely not
played final fantasy
is it is it really it doesn't have you
played final fantasy vii no you haven't
you haven't you don't know i haven't
finished it
i'm sorry i wouldn't count that wait you
when wait the remake no the the original
what you've played the original final
fantasy vii i got like 10 hours in and i
quit
what
years ago
i actually don't believe you how have
you never mentioned this before because
i didn't finish it
but you've played it yeah i've played it
you know the basic concept of it yeah
why have we never talked about this
because i didn't really like it that
much
wait so you've owned the ps1 no no i got
it's on steam
yeah so you've played it in your adult
life uh yeah when i was like 18.
what
it used to go on like steam sales all
the time
oh my god wow that was literally the
first figure i stole and i i know that
that was the first figure right
if you bought that i didn't i didn't
beat it i didn't mean it i didn't read
it but you played it yeah it doesn't say
you need it to be true yeah so
so like mostly i looked around on the
second floor and i didn't notice that
there were arc night figures on the
second floor until people were talking
about it yeah i don't know because i
shall argue yeah i had such little time
that i spent so much time trying to buy
the most expensive figure that i just
like lost all my time so i didn't see
any arc like figures um and then i went
downstairs because all basically all of
the second floor were like expensive
gaming figures which are just like
basically fate and final fantasy which i
didn't know that you played all right so
that would have played fate
yeah i know i know i know you haven't
played fakes
um so i go downstairs and uh i don't
really see much it's again it's mostly
anime figures
um and then i see
i see a shelf
and it's all persona and i was thinking
i was saying to myself i've been trying
to convince conor to play persona for
two [ __ ] years and it has led up to
this point and i was pissed that connor
if you were a good friend you would have
taken my recommendation and started
playing persona 5 but no one time i
played placenta in your house for like
15 minutes
does that count i don't know if that
goes
i just saw god be like
we did oh [ __ ] we have we did we were we
were very intoxicated and that's why
that's the only time i remember
what can you even do in persona 5 for 15
minutes what happened was i was watching
uh sydney go around some uh like it
looked like a digital maze or something
a mentos
no no it's one of it was one of the uh
dungeons all the later dungeons
give me the control i'll do it the loss
and then i got lost too
so it didn't really help wow yeah i
spent a good 20 minutes so technically i
have played with something yeah i
haven't played it much but yeah
yeah but then the third one i saw was a
mega man one and
conor's never talked about mega man
before right i don't have have you ever
heard him talk about mega man i've
talked about mega man on the show and i
don't think he was like he's never
mentioned it but like but like i saw
mega man and i'm just like mega man
seems like a conor game you know it's
it's it's like i could see connor
playing maternity as a platformer it's a
shooting platformer yeah yeah like you
used to speed run cuphead right yeah
yeah yeah exactly but like but like i
didn't know
if like
did you own a nintendo i what what is
your game console history because like
this made me question what your game
console history was because i'm like you
can play final fantasy because you don't
own a ps1 i had a nintendo 64. nintendo
64. my parents took it away because they
thought games were evil yeah and i
managed to convince them to get me uh
ps1 i broke then i got a ps2 and i got a
gamecube and a wii
then an xbox and now pc most of the
mainline consoles yeah so i remember so
i didn't think connor would be old
enough to have like a super nintendo or
nintendo and like where else you play
mega man apart from the old school
consoles right pretty much um so have
you played mega man because i didn't get
it not like fully i've played it at like
you know like friend's house for like a
few right like no i've never like
committed to sit down and people yeah it
is a very good like
pick up and play i would say no i
haven't if you ask me
if i got the figure now and i'm just
like connor it's amazing
that story be like no i haven't played
that
because i wouldn't yeah because i
remember conor was like i'm an xbox kid
and i'm like okay xbox is like gamecube
era i'll stretch it out and say maybe he
had a lot
of this figure man
and then and then sydney came in clutch
and was just like gone how can you
forget literally the most successful
franchise in the [ __ ] world
how can you forget the one that's
literally right in front of your face
literally the most successful franchise
in the world and it's a tiny figure
because i it's a pikachu figure okay
is that the uh the anime edition
220 yen
and i i got this not forgetting that
whoever gets the least expensive figure
um i might have just [ __ ] myself over
by uh earning a point and then losing a
point uh otherwise i would have got
something more expensive maybe you
should uh keep track of that yeah that
might very much be a contender yeah
that's fine that's an okay he's
definitely
i know you've played pokemon uh we've
talked about it several times and even
if we hadn't talked about it i could
like you could you could bring this to
like
90 of anime fans or just people in
general they probably would have played
pokemon yeah there was also cyberpunk
overwatch a bunch of other actual was
that cyberpunk
ones yeah was that one the one on the
first floor or second floor second floor
both a lot of the games were actually on
the second floor yeah right yeah also uh
i i me and connor found a bunch of apex
figures uh at army army yeah yeah yeah i
saw army army at apex figures
congratulations on completing your first
challenge yeah you got it thank you what
a build-up
i just wanted to tell you